Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody. Let's get right
into it, because there's so much to cover.
One of the most sort of stubborn, specific talking
points about so-called election fraud in general
and about the 2020 election is this idea of
dead voters voting now by dead voters voting?
It's not literally people
risen from the grave like,
you know, whatever religious analogy you want to
use. The idea is people who have died have votes
counted in their name by a live person,
a living person who goes and says,
I am this person or that person. And depending on
which flavor of this conspiracy theory you choose,
it can be supposedly a strategy for those who
wish to steal an election. To find large numbers
of names of dead people still on voter rolls,
show up and say, I'm that person, and to vote
or to do it via absentee ballot. Another one
of these studies of this has been done. And it
turns out that 5000 supposedly dead Georgia voters
have been found alive and well. This is a study
from the Atlanta Journal Constitution. It's
worth reading the entire article, but to give you
the gist of it, it says false claims that there
were thousands of ballots cast in the names
of dead Georgia voters can now rest in peace.
Election investigators found four absentee ballots
four in the 2020 presidential election from
voters who had died, all of them returned by
relatives. Now that number four can be looked at
in more detail. The State Election Board referred
the cases to the Attorney General's Office. The
tiny number of ballots cast on behalf of deceased
voters contrasts with Trump's accusation of 5000
dead voters in Georgia in there. It's the latest
in a series of unsubstantiated claims. In what?
So here's an example. In one case, a 74 year old
widow submitted an absentee ballot on behalf of
her husband after he died. This is a this is one.
This is a legitimate case of that happening,
she said. He was going to vote Republican.
I'm going to cancel your ballot by voting
Democrat. It was a joke between them,
and she got an absentee ballot
in her deceased husband's name
and carried out his wishes. She realizes it
was the wrong thing to do. And Georgia election
officials say there need to be consequences even
for a mistake, so they are presumably going to be
prosecuting that. In another case, a ballot was
submitted for deceased Augusta voter Leon Roe.
Investigators found that the signature on his
absentee ballot matched the handwriting of his
mother. Who died in October of 2020.
So they found four instances now.
Unfortunately, there are people who will see
that and they will say, see, it does happen.
And of course, in a country of three hundred and
thirty one million, as we always say, you can find
examples of everything. But to go from that to, it
would have changed the results in even one county,
never mind and even one state, never mind changing
the electoral votes. It's not there, and I want to
remind everybody of a really good study carried
out by the BBC where they looked into this in
Michigan, and this is an article from November of
2020. And they did a really interesting thing. The
Trumpists were vaguely saying 10000 dead people
voted in Michigan, and they had a list of the BBC,
picked 30 names at random. And then they added the
oldest person on the list. So they had 31 names,
11 of them. They spoke to the person or a family
member or coworker and confirmed that they were
actually still alive. 11 of the 31 dead voters
in Michigan were alive for 17 others. There
was no public record of their death. And they
found clear evidence that the person was alive.
And then they found three people who were dead
and looked into those cases in more detail.
One of them was like a senior junior confusion,
and I believe two of them were people who
submitted their absentee ballots and later died.
So when you hear all of the story, which is
there's tons of fraud, dead people voting, people
voting twice, undocumented immigrants vote.
Wow, that sounds like a lot. And then you realize
it's merely a Gish gallop and you examine each of
these claims individually. And then with just the
dead voters, you go and you look at names and then
you find out they're mostly alive. There is four
people in this case where the allegation is true.
Sometimes it's junior senior confusion, etc.
They all fall apart and only when you break the
claim down into its sort of component parts do you
really understand that there is nothing there. And
one other note on this is when people actually
do the things that they are accused of doing
by the right. They seem to pretty regularly get
caught when it's investigated, which is another
sign that, generally speaking, the elections
are pretty secure. The counter side to this is
that when the intelligence community really issues
warnings about things like foreign interference in
elections, the very Republicans who will claim
they actually won due to insecure elections
often want to do nothing about real attempts
by foreign powers to meddle in the elections.
And it shouldn't surprise us because it's here is
the stated value which they abandon as soon as the
facts on the ground conflict with what they want.
So another study debunking the dead voter myth